welcome back to this special edition of
hannity
yesterday as texas continued to suffer
under a massive and deadly winter storm
the commander in chief
joe biden took a snow day watch this
where's our commander in chief you know
that new guy
oh that's right this morning he decided
to take a snow day
the guy ultimately in charge of fema and
all the country's emergency resources
and federal agencies yeah he took a day
off
in the middle of this natural disaster
where's the
feign phony uh selective liberal outrage
on this i guess
you know to be fair it's not even really
totally clear that
joe even fully understands what's going
on in texas
after this show last night the biden
team felt the need to release
a tweet assuring voters that the
president called
texas governor greg abbott biden now
plans to visit
the state sometime after the weather
warms up
no doubt democrats will use the winter
storm as a political tool to push their
radical agenda
already the united states has re-entered
the paris climate accord
no time to waste apparently biden's
green
energy oracle john kerry now claims we
have just
nine years to save the planet joining us
now with
more is former energy secretary and
former
texas governor rick perry i guess i'll
call you governor
because that's how i got to know you
best and uh i think i appreciate you
you joining us this to me is going to be
what i call a disaster liberalism this
is classic disaster liberalism
disaster happens and they want to have a
solution and their solution is usually
more government more regulation
but that's not how we're actually going
to solve these problems than these
challenges is it government more
government more regulation
exactly right jason and uh thanks for
having me on
uh you know i'd i'd love to have
president biden come to texas uh we can
we can show him some things that he
certainly needs to see
uh what's going on with this crisis is
one of them and kind of explain to him
why we need the federal government to be
a
partner in innovating our way
uh to better energy solutions rather
than
regulating and that's what i worry about
when people talk about well let's get in
the federal
uh the national grid and i'm like
let's let's just tap the brakes on that
let's talk about it
certainly let's hear what that would
mean
but i'm telling you my experience with
the federal government has been
the first thing they do is regulate
and we got these great national labs
jason as you know 17 national labs
uh across this country that do some
extraordinary work
whether it's in the areas of small
modular reactors whether it's in
compact fusion reactors we're seeing
some fabulous things out there on fuel
cells
and hydrogen i mean all of those are
areas that we could innovate
but let's let's be clear here this was a
once
probably once in a lifetime event that
happened in texas
a lot of reasons that it happened uh you
know
people are pointing fingers over at the
wind industry people are pointing
fingers over here at urcot they're
saying
here's i i would just i would caution
folks
look let's find solutions
every time there's a national or a
natural disaster rather
in the state when i was governor we
learned something from it so
what is it that we we've learned from
this
uh we obviously didn't have the
weatherization going on that we should
have had uh
we need to have more diversity in our
in our portfolio i think walking away
from
fossil fuels walking away from nuclear
is an
absolute uh recipe for disaster
so i i'd love for the president to to
come to texas and and we
matter of fact i'd love for him to come
down to the border
and talk to the people along the border
of texas
and find out how misguided this
immigration policy is that he's trying
to uh
to push through that would be an
absolute disaster and i'm telling you
a lot of those folks along the border
down there historically voted democrat
and they never will again if he
carries through with this very very
bad immigration policy he's talking
about
so uh governor you know to hear joe
biden the president
talk about this he believes that the
paris climate accord is going to help
save these
uh save the situation i what's your
reaction when you see that i mean that's
job one right out of the box that's
exactly what he's doing as if that's
gonna help solve the problem
the trump administration made
substantial
increases uh in clean energy
they did some things on the emission
sides american natural gas
was going to europe replacing older
inefficient power plants not to mention
the
reliance upon russian gas
and to hear john kerry and
and joe biden talk about it uh those are
disastrous policies
well emissions from electrical
power generation in america
is down to 1987 levels jason i mean
isn't that good and that what our goal
was to reduce emissions
and american natural gas that
was developed through hydraulic
fracturing directional drilling
was right at the heart of that and so
fossil fuels
and i'll tell you last week in texas as
people
were losing their power thank god we had
fossil fuels in this in this state
because if all we had had was the aoc
green new deal plan with
wind and solar we would have had a
massive
disaster on our hands as it was fossil
fuels
are what really saved the day here so i
think it's
the wise move here is come up with the
innovation
look at a lot of different ways to
create new diversity
use all of your natural resources wisely
cleanly which we have done in this
country
all the climate agreement is going to do
is to let countries like china off the
hook
they're going to continue to you know
develop their
energy resources climate be damned
and america will pay the price i don't i
don't understand why
john kerry and and president biden can't
see the truth to that
well they they live in a different
bubble and it's the washington dc
bubble and it's not rooted in reality
but governor i thank you for your time
and service as governor and his
secretary and uh
for you and all your fellow texans out
there stay warm and uh get past this and
let's get that innovation in place
so we never have to answer it again
thank you this will be in our time
we'll learn from it though we'll learn
from it thank you again rick perry
thanks for joining us tonight